there we go since the 1960s and percent
of the US population that moves in any
given year has fallen by 50%
research suggests that Americans today
are less geographically mobile than at
any point since the late 1940s there's a
bigger problem here than just boring
scenery a mobile opportunistic workforce
can claim higher salaries and make our
economy more dynamic so what happened
several things millenials are moving out
and starting their own lives at an
historically low pace older people feel
trapped and undervalued home waiting on
the housing market and some safety net
programs trap Bulbul americans in place
instead of helping them move to new
opportunities what can we do about it
to start with we could redirect some
safety net funding towards relocation
vouchers and make social programs more
flexible let's empower people to move
instead of anchoring them in place but
policy can only do so much the core
issue is culture we need to rediscover
the entrepreneurial frontier spirit that
defined our country for generations for
America to really get moving again
Americans will need to get moving again
to learn more about how to get Americans
moving again check the links in the
description below also let us know what
other topics you want a EEI scholars to
cover in 60 seconds